i'm talking about reality
feel it feel this in your [ __ ] heart
doc [ __ ] us
there you go
[ __ ] seven when this came out i still
remember walking from 205 west 88th
street to like a hundred and [ __ ]
12th to some music store to buy it it
[ __ ] just
puts me there on a sunday night
tremendous what's happening people
nothing
can't call it leah sayet and i went to
vegas this weekend yeah
thank you for inviting me no please you
were going to sit at home the girlfriend
was [ __ ] studying over weekend right
uh i said [ __ ] it let's go i was going
to do friday night at south point south
point dirty at 12 30 which will get you
on we'll get you in the rotation vegas
by the way i've been to vegas like four
or five times now every time i go to the
south point i like it more i hate the
strip
the rooms are beautiful and it's you're
off the [ __ ] thing you take a cab
and you're away from everybody you want
to park you don't shoot in there there's
no need to go to the strip they have a
movie theater a bowling alley bars a ton
of restaurants [ __ ] rounds
yeah they got a movie theater so when
you perform there over the weekend you
just go to the lobby go upstairs they
got midnight bowling oh
thank you i'll massage it
that's when the devil shows up yeah
that's how you get tetanus of the tongue
what'd you lose how much
uh 200. that's it all together stop no
yeah that's all that's what plus the
money in the sock no no i just dropped
it but
every 20 it killed you that's what you
could hear in your voice it doesn't kill
me like i just
i'm just doing it for fun now but it's
like i went to a different hotel uh last
night because i got to stay for the
fights
and like the degenerate gamblers there
were just crazy they had conspiracy the
casino was conspiring against them and
this guy lost seven thousand dollars i'm
like i just want to have fun yeah so 200
bucks to me that's not gonna
it was fun
but i had a great time
i was uh
i had always heard about vegas vegas
vegas wait till you go to vegas
you're gonna have a great time in vegas
and the first time i went to vegas i
know it was the coke i had
but from the time i got off the plane
to the time i got to the hotel it just
didn't feel right
and i went up to the whole i don't
remember what hotel i stayed at or
like we flew from newark to
i think i stayed for two days i remember
always feeling uneasy
and then i went back with some guys that
were decent guys and i didn't do drugs
and i don't know i just i i saw
what i always didn't want to be
like that thing i didn't want to be
at the time so it always scared me a
little bit too much because that could
have been me i could have been hanging
out the sports books
with tickets ripping them up in the
[ __ ] air with pawn tickets and my
thing yeah yeah my wife calling me
where's the [ __ ] lunch money that
could have been me i had an addictive
personality yeah and i went through that
at an early age but then i realized i
didn't like giving up my money i didn't
[ __ ] like it i didn't like giving
somebody money on a thursday because i'd
been on some [ __ ] basketball team and
they didn't cover the spread so
i don't know i just never felt easy in
vegas right whether i went and got taken
care of or it didn't matter i just never
felt the
no a lot of people don't like it
but the like the food is great that's uh
i i called my mom today on the drive
back and i was like thank you for not
taking me to casinos there was a lot of
kids there this weekend
like little breathing cigarettes and
[ __ ] there was one lady carrying one
breastfeeding one with that [ __ ]
uh
addictive personality in the air he's
sucking your titty
i don't know i don't know what kids do
there and talking lair always says oh
there's a bunch of stuff to do but the
parents who are there don't want to go
to like the kid stuff well they drop you
off i went there when i was a kid my
very first time there i was like six or
seven
and then we went to circus circus and
they have like a daycare
and you play with a bunch of other
strange kids whose parents don't give a
[ __ ]
and uh
you spend a lot of time there
and you wait for them to come back and
get you that's crazy and that's what
happens i don't have a need
to go to vegas and take the baby
and then there's my wife i offered her i
said do you want to come for this trip
we'll take a southwest flight be there
now and she was like i really don't want
to you know
i don't have a need to walk through a
[ __ ] casino
with my child but that's me everybody
has different
ideas on whatever everybody has
different needs people want to go to a
pool whatever the [ __ ] you know yeah
[ __ ] yeah ours was my my mom and dad at
the time step dad they were broke and so
the cheapest thing to do is get like a
room in vegas
we go through circus circus they drop us
off with a little daycare then they go
gamble or whatever or maybe they go back
to the room and [ __ ] i don't know and
then we all go back to the hotel room we
eat at a buffet and then we all go back
to the hotel room
and yeah
yeah that's what happened when i was a
kid they didn't take me
to vegas but they took me to miami beach
with titties was everywhere and this is
when this is the 70s the mid 70s
there was bikinis there wasn't no nude
beach then that i knew it was as it just
was a lot of hairy armpits and hairy
crotch i would see bikinis and i'd be
curious i'm not going to lie i saw a rat
one time that always stayed with me by
the pool at the the hawaiian house or
whatever the [ __ ] it was at the time
they had seven pools
so every year what we did was i would go
down there the first
week of july and i'd stayed on for like
a week and a half two weeks
and then the following weekend my mother
would come down from new york and we'd
rent the hotel with miami family
on the beach and we'd get a different
hotel but it was all up to the kids
because we pool hot at night
it was from a shitty hotel to the
newport hotel and we just go down south
miami beach this is
30 [ __ ] years before south beach ever
was hit this is north miami beach the
old miami beach
and i remember going from like the
castaways but the castaways i think
don't quote me on this had seven
swimming pools
that's crazy swimming pools were always
fun that's the [ __ ] lure for me i was
a new york city kid i always wanted you
know my cousins could walk barefoot in
the sun i couldn't [ __ ] do that as a
kid
because your feet burned yeah my feet
were burning they would walk for a mile
with those [ __ ]
feet on thick because they were used to
it i was never used to that type of [ __ ]
used to drive me crazy so i liked all
that swimming and stuff and i remember
being by the pool one night
like 9 30 being like nine and [ __ ]
and i'm from new york city i've killed
some rats
and i'm sitting there i ain't hot
i ain't nothing at the time that's what
you did as a kid in new york city on the
street you killed rats
like one every summer would pop out and
you chase it and [ __ ] get behind the
car and then you'd corner and hit it
with sticks and you [ __ ] throw rocks
at it and you hit with more sticks then
you drag it out and you keep hitting it
and then cars would drive over it
and then you put it somewhere where a
car would drive over it then you dragged
it back with the stick and you hit it
more then you put it with rocks then you
got some glue or gasoline you pour it on
you let it on fire
and then once you turned it off you hit
it with some more [ __ ] sticks that's
howly
like i slaughtered that [ __ ] i just have
this image of like you looking the same
but being really short
just hitting the sticks
i'd be like 20 puerto rican kids oh my
god but i remember being on the beach
one night and just looking at the ocean
i wasn't on the beach i was a scary cat
okay so this is the beach
this is a wall
there's a place where people could lie
you know like when they they lie like
this and get the sun like backwards on
those beach chairs and they went around
the pool i was in this way looking at
the ocean and also i'm sitting there
right
minding my own [ __ ] business i look
over i see some movement like that ain't
nothing moving
leave this had to be
probably a [ __ ] foot and a half rat
oh no and i saw his little tail squirm
and i just froze i had seen him in new
york pretty big but this one took the
[ __ ] cake
jesus i don't know i don't know if i've
ever seen a rat oh my god he just
randomly you've never seen a rat i don't
know i mean i lived in boston but i
don't
i think i might have seen him in new
york on the subway but not like not like
huge like that then about five minutes
later
and the crab was chasing him
[ __ ] like down little crab walking
backwards whatever the [ __ ] they're
doing i'm like i'm out of here
that was it for me no more miami beach
this is real jack
you know i like going to the beach and
picking up seashells and [ __ ] and
listening
but this is [ __ ] real where'd you
grow up tiffany i grew up in south
central los angeles ocean yeah born and
raised born and raised i always lived in
l.a
high school
i went to el camino real high school in
woodland hills california i was best get
up every morning at 5 00 a.m
and walk down to the bus stop and
yeah
go to school
okay so they bust you from
south central to woodland hills now
where you grew up uh
you know
lee always talks about where his
girlfriend lived and where they moved
from
in contrast to what america sees on
television
where is this from where you grew up
what pride like what tv show have you
seen and go that's why i grew up like
where my wisha was living like militia
that tv show my wish with brandy she was
living in la mer park area like so i'm
like right down the street from there
you know what's going on alvarado
no not alvarado is crenshaw okay
paula always brings up training day is
it like that oh that's the jungles i was
i lived in the jungles for a little bit
that's on the other side of the crenshaw
mall
where i grew up mostly well where i
spent the majority of my time was over
by the slauson swap meet or
where um the the coliseum i believe yeah
the coliseum is right down the street
that's like two miles away usc over
there usc yeah
and they bust you
from down there to woodland hills
who made that decision the state the
city um
i guess this my school i don't know uh
they have passed on some papers called
choices
they did that in massachusetts where i
grew up they didn't send white kids they
they sent kids from the city to the
suburbs yeah yeah they send nice white
kids and that they sound like black yeah
puerto ricans
no puerto ricans a couple asians you sit
there and go what the [ __ ] is this what
we do deserve this [ __ ] [ __ ]
no they just sent it they just sent
black kids and hispanic kids into
woodland hills but i don't remember them
sending any to them
at all no that is because our schools
were overcrowded they were saying and so
at first like i said to hell middle
school once i had graduated from uh
elementary i went to hale middle school
and that was interesting
yeah
that was my first time around a lot of
white people
i only thought that white people lived
in tv that's what i thought like in my
mind all white people lived in tv and
whenever the police would go by her
someone be like oh look they're going to
go from chips this is so [ __ ] cool
like you know or if the social worker
showed up i'd be like oh my goodness she
was on murder she wrote i think she was
on murder she wrote like everybody i
associated with people on television
that's just what i did so when i went to
hell middle school and it's like all
white it's in whittling hills oh my god
and i get there and i'm like oh my
goodness i'm at the nickelodeon awards
this is so cool i need to dress better
like
so i wore my like church dress for the
next three days like i was really around
a bunch of celebrities and then i made a
friend and i found out that her mama
gave food stamps too and i was like oh
[ __ ] you just like my mama
y'all ain't [ __ ] yeah
mm-hmm white chick that her mama had
food stamps
and i was like
well anyway when did you decide that you
liked
movies and all this [ __ ] that we do
uh when i when i decided like comedy
yeah in high school yeah with comedy
yeah i decided in high school like
entertaining people that happened to me
in sixth grade
it was black history month right and i
was diana ross and my two friends that
were twins was the supremes behind me
right and we was dressed all sexy and
stuff looking all good big hair
everything looking as sexy as a sixth
grader can look you know what i'm saying
and uh i had on heels now we have been
doing shows we had already did like five
shows and kilted every show everybody
clapped for us the first graders third
graders they loved us right so then
we're doing the parents program
and the boy that i like a lot is at this
show
he's sitting right in the front okay i
come out as diana ross i'm like stop in
the name of love
before you break my heart and i'm
singing it all hard and stuff even
though the record player is playing way
louder than my little microphone but i'm
singing it from my heart and we move to
the side and me and the girls that
talked about this if somebody fall we
all fall like it's like part of their
act right so we take two steps to the
side i fall i slip over the cord fall
down
leg goes over the side of the stage
dress up everybody see my flower panties
i kick the record player
i get the record player when i try to
get back up on the stage and then the
boy i like this is looking at me and i
look i turn around look at the audience
and i look at these [ __ ] they looking
at me like damn [ __ ] you just showed
your ass right it they didn't say that
we was in sixth grade they was just like
oh my god
and then i just looked at everybody and
i started crying and i run to the back
and then my sixth grade teacher miss
matoya
she come back there and she got a big
ass mom she got a mole like i got but
hers like has a eyeball and [ __ ] like
it's another person and she come back
there and she pointed she pointed her
finger in my face she goes you gonna sit
back here and cry like a punk or you
don't get your ass on that stage and
finish this goddamn song you gotta
finish the song and i was like
she's like you're gonna see you're gonna
cry like a punk you're gonna cry like
are you a puck are you a puck and i was
like no i'm not a punk i'm not a puncher
like get your ass up and get back on the
stage so i get up i go back on the stage
they have fixed the record player by
then boom the song comes on the curtains
open right and i'm singing but it's
tears coming down my face is the whole
audience gets up and they start clapping
and [ __ ] and i hear this one lady she's
like that girl got courage that girl got
courage and i'm like stupid
i'm crying through the whole thing and
then the boy that i liked was like
afterwards
but the thing that made me decide though
to be an entertainer was that it felt
super good for autumn people to stand up
and clap for me and i'm crying and that
lady said i had courage and i was like
i'm always gonna i said to myself in
that moment i always want to feel like
this and i always am gonna have that
thing that's gonna push me through no
matter what but then the boy that i
liked right he came up he said you look
so beautiful when you first came out and
then you failed and i thought that was
funny
but then i saw your panties and i was
like damn she's got on some nice panties
i was like you think my panties were
nice how old were you 12. you were dirty
freaky
i was in sixth grade and then he said
yeah you had some nice flower panties
and then but he said but when you
started to cry that was ugly that was
really really ugly and then he said but
then when you came back out and those
tears were running down your face
i thought to myself yeah tiffany's
really beautiful and that's like the
first time a boy said i was beautiful
and i was like you think so and i tried
to kiss me he's like what the [ __ ] is
you doing
and he just mushed my face
but
what do you want to be at 12 leigh i was
just thinking about that
i don't know i i've read a veterinarian
for a while but i i didn't think i could
like cut open like an animal what kind
of animal did you have at the house i
didn't i didn't have a dog until
i was like 13 or 14 that was when i
first got my dog what did you want to do
with ten did you want to be a superhero
ever or a comedian
did you want probably a superhero did
you yeah i had jobs like in second grade
i started a weeding company i did like
three jobs i put a sign up at the end of
my driveway and like my parents friends
would hire me to like weed their gardens
now you are a gardener not for like two
days i i always had little jobs get you
mexican for two days
pretty much
yeah i i always had little businesses
like i thought right when the internet
came out my dad had got one of one of
the first computers and i thought we
could do a business where we could print
out stuff people wanted to read and sell
them the pages and
i don't know
why do you ask me these questions when
i'm super high because i didn't i'm i'm
sitting here listening to tiffany i
didn't know what we had never discussed
that you wanted to be at 12 like uh
did you ever think you'd be doing this
like why what oh
my dad was doing this when i was that
age my dad did radio for 25 years
probably up until i was like 15.
and i i still to this day i can't listen
to the podcast i'm on because i hate the
sound of my voice but why it's so sexy
now when did you decide to go to the
entertainment college
i i decided to do that
up until my junior year of high school i
thought i was gonna go into marketing
just because i thought it was like what
like a real job
but i had always i had done every single
video production class in my high school
so much that i started i was a ta like
an assistant
my junior and senior year
and i went to visit a couple colleges
like bentley a business college and it
was just so boring i didn't i didn't
like it and i went to see emerson and
just decided to go for it
i think i got 12 i wanted to be a
soldier
jesus why look what kind of soldier like
a soldier just like a gi joe type
soldier jesus like i thought that's what
i was supposed to do
to go to service and i'd come out and do
something else i didn't know i was like
a blind alliance did you hear what's
happening a lot now what's up there's
people dressing up in fake armor
uniforms
and going out and trying to get free
stuff and there's this one dude who put
a video up like taunting people like i'm
gonna i'm still gonna do it it's called
like stolen valor or something people
pretending they're they're soldiers well
yeah so people have been doing it for 20
[ __ ] thousand years people have been
people that
join the service
and then realize it's not for them but
they heard something but now every time
you see them they wear the [ __ ]
outfit and they tell you how they went
to boot camp
and they almost got deployed but they
got the flu
they tell you some story it's it's you
know it's this
[ __ ] up thing i didn't know why i
wanted to be a soldier i just thought
that's what you
did you know at that age when did you
decide to be become a comedian
i don't know
i really don't know
i really don't [ __ ] know by the age
of like 12 or 13 i had already heard
prior
i had already heard that and it was
mind-boggling it was mind-boggling we
were saying it was mind-boggling on the
stage and
said that but it was the farthest thing
from my [ __ ] mind you know
it was nowhere even the horizon
i thought i would either be a soldier or
go to school and be an attorney again it
was blind alliance
allegiance i didn't know what it
entailed i didn't know you had to go to
seven years of [ __ ] law school no
so it's just interesting you would be a
great lawyer no i always wanted to be a
lawyer that was my
if you would do all the reading and all
that [ __ ] you got to do
that would have been fun school to me
was always very simple i i got left back
not because i was stupid in
the seventh grade but because i fell in
love with [ __ ]
and it just took me like it just took me
i mean
she wasn't really giving me [ __ ]
she was just giving me the whiff
she was letting me dry hump and sniff
her titties
and that was and every once in a while
just touch ride a bug just grab a little
head
like just below the panty i just grabbed
a little head and she grabbed my hand
it was crazy and i just got under
it was over tiffany had anyway once you
got in it was that was it you hooked up
because that [ __ ] could be like you
sniffed her boobs
you know when you're [ __ ] 11 or 12
what do you think you do you don't know
what the [ __ ] you do this is all
experimental right before you do a
one-man show you take it to the comedy
central stage and you do experimental
[ __ ] you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
doing you read about magazines whatever
you hear from your parents whatever you
hear on the street from the city pervert
you know this this the sidewalk pervert
that's what you do i don't know if you
sniff a dick
i don't know you sounded like you
remembered sniffing a tip well i got
into that fetish later on when i got
like 13 i would go to women's houses
that i knew like my mom's friends and
i'd asked to go to the bathroom i locked
the door and in those days women would
always have
two things in the bathroom in those days
every woman had a douche bag
hanging from the from the [ __ ] shower
they would hang those douche bags yeah
like a bag
with a tube with a [ __ ] head with
things with a sprinkler at the end i
never sniffed one of those i always
looked at it and thought about it i
ain't gonna sit here and tell you i
never thought about sniffing the [ __ ]
handle on a douchebag but i wasn't that
perverted i wasn't that god
yeah i was i was settled with the bra
i got very tight with the bra like i
would sniff the middle of the bra and
get dizzy and [ __ ]
so that was my nipple sweat yeah it was
it was just uh
you know
i i always think that's very interesting
to think back what you really want to do
at 12
then what you popped in your [ __ ]
head what you want to do with 16. right
listen to 16 you hear your [ __ ] [ __ ]
friends talking and you're like at 16
now it's 16 what were you thinking
um marketing but it yeah
i was thinking um some sort of
entertainer but i didn't know what i
knew i wanted to be an entertainer
singing dancing you didn't know what to
do i didn't know what but something
whatever did you go to college i felt
like yeah i went to community college
for a little bit i got accepted in the
nyu but i didn't go because i didn't
want to leave my brothers and sisters
behind
i didn't want to leave the state i was
scared too
so i just went to santa monica and i was
like a freshman there and they let me be
in the play and they don't even let
freshmen in place
at junior college but they let me in
because i'm talented that was it and
that was it i was on there i mean then i
started working at the airline for a
little bit but yeah
what else did you work at i worked at
american air new zealand and alaska at
lax yes lax and what did you do i was
customer service i provided excellent
service too it's the best jesus christ
what year did you quit over there uh
2003
no [ __ ]
did you have fly benefits and everything
yeah
it was pretty nice it's not yeah it was
nice i traveled around you know this
little ratchet-ness here and there and
uh
yeah you weren't doing comedy right now
i started doing comedy in 2001
to 2001 or two now we hooked up in 2005
his friends you myself rafi made
that's who we met
and we were discussing the time we we
went outside in front of the live
factory we had a showcase we were all at
the same agency at the time
and we had a showcase and after we were
in front of there
and if i remember good nights in
hollywood it was one of those nights
where you're just talking to people and
just have and nobody else mattered it
was just me you and around for you
telling you you had nappy hair then yeah
your [ __ ] wasn't tight but you were very
beautiful i remember going this [ __ ]
gonna check his [ __ ] badass
just dropping truth which a lot of
people don't know
don't do in this town you know
you were talking about your struggles
you know before and what a woman has to
do and it's uh
you don't hear that much anymore peop
that part of the election and what guys
have to do you know i did some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] from 21 to 25 you know
you do it some of you remember something
you don't [ __ ] remember
you know you do some crap
one time getting evicted from a
[ __ ] hotel
for what and knowing it because i didn't
have the rent
when i left there i told him i'd have to
rent it one
i got paid at five i was working for a
brick mason
i worked all [ __ ] week for maybe 250
dollars carrying bricks and making water
i knew i was going to leave it was 1985.
i knew i was leaving jersey
and i get to the hotel like what's up
man they go hey man we threw you out
some indian guys like we drew you out
your stuff is in front of the hotel at
that time i had a duffel bag and that
was everything guys damn i had an army
duffel bag a blue army duffel bag that
had been around the world and back scam
i'm back to cars you know
that thing has been everywhere and i go
over there and there it is
the army is right there
but i listen to the door
and there's some something's going on in
there
so i still had the key i stuck the key
and i opened the door
and i hear a girl giggling and a guy
and i look and they're in the shower
[ __ ]
and the steam is coming out and i look
at the bed and they've been [ __ ]
look at the bureau and there's a wallet
and an envelope filled with [ __ ]
money
i just take the [ __ ] money i take the
[ __ ] wallet i close the door gently
i grab that duffel bag and i run like a
[ __ ]
i run like a [ __ ]
across route 4 whatever is going into
the george washington bridge
there i am running with this [ __ ]
thing i make a left the [ __ ] right
and right there ran that area like i saw
a cab and i go dog
uh let's take let's go into the city i
look in the envelope and it's [ __ ]
50s and hundreds
you know that was that prostitute's
money she mad as she no it was like it
was like uh the money they brought back
money like a bank money
it wasn't those are brand new fifties
and hundreds he my politicians about to
pay his house i paid the guy 50 bucks he
took me into
port authority in new york i walked up
the corner
i checked the blue [ __ ] duffel bag
and port authority there they used to be
lockers
boom i put the lock on 178 i cleaned out
the wallet in the men's bathroom i took
the [ __ ] cash out of the envelope it
must have been like four thousand
dollars on a friday night at six o'clock
here i'm carrying bricks with 250 a
[ __ ] week
i remember [ __ ] going to my
neighborhood buying a bag of rock
walking two more blocks buying a bag of
[ __ ] reefer that's when i used to go
right by the carville there and there
was a dude who sold chocolate tie weed
and then like three blocks down you
bought some powder and i went right back
to port authority
checked my [ __ ] bag out of the thing
got right back on the bus right back to
fort lee got a cab and he took me to a
hotel like three down from the hotel i
had just robbed
from the gas station i had robbed
three weeks earlier what i robbed that
gas station right by the hotel three
weeks earlier not at gunpoint wow i did
an application this is [ __ ] craziness
so what i'm trying to say to you is we
do crazy things yeah and i like that
right now you think about it and go joey
that was pretty [ __ ] sleazy maybe
those people put away the money we
didn't give a [ __ ] about that i probably
got beat up yeah at that night that was
no i don't know if she was a hooker
maybe they were lovers
maybe who [ __ ] fell that man is
accusing her probably to this day of
stealing his [ __ ] she probably he's like
i wouldn't get in her [ __ ] i know it
like
whoever was looking over me the guardian
angel that night
i went in and out of there
like they [ __ ] got out of bed and go
what happened to my money
i put no i left onto jesus do you think
so oh my god call the police at that
time i would have called up
and i was stupid in hindsight i went to
a hotel like three but it was a nicer
type of hotel
i checked on and those days you have to
have my d no
you just told me your name was [ __ ]
joey labamba
yeah
how many times did you just run into
hundreds and thousands of dollars you've
told me like seven stories i know he
always got a theft story
it's uh it was an uncanny thing like you
have to think you had some type of
guardian angel so like we were at the
ufc and that tip jar would you have
taken that
before no no no i wasn't to that level
no okay no no what do you know i'm a ufc
sitting down having a good time with you
take a tip jar they're gonna everything
is on camera i know now but even then no
no no no no no no no i'm not saying now
you're gonna steal anything you don't
need to steal anything now no no no
i'm like i'm not laughing because i took
a tip jaw i'm laughing about a dear
friend of mine
that said one night he was in the club
and i have another dear friend he's no
longer with us but i loved him like a
brother
one of my all-time favorite people
tiffany addison he was crazy
this guy was like five foot six and he
was [ __ ] yoked up he had been doing
steroids since he was 15.
the dudes he was doing steroids with
were gay
but he was sharing a needle he ended up
getting hepatitis c
this [ __ ] didn't give a [ __ ]
we'd be at a bar drinking snot and coke
and i got money
darren take off your shirt do push-ups
get a bar packed in jersey take off your
shirts do push it i tell him jump on the
bar do the crab he'd jump up there
oh my god my point i'm [ __ ] higher
than [ __ ] oh i know oh so i had never
been to ufc before like thank you he's
not gonna listen but thank you to jeff
for giving me the tickets but i get to
the hotel before we even go up to the
room you break out a joint
then you take me over and give me half a
cheap you're not gonna be a half
i was at least a third it was a third it
was a third i didn't give you happy
because i knew
you couldn't handle what
when i give happened a half of the 70s
you can't handle it no so i would never
do that to you during the thing you
would have an anxiety attack which you
already had during the intro of the ufc
tiffany is so strong like it's so
music the [ __ ] videos the the music
it's so strong and i knew it would take
it takes me still yeah that's my
favorite part
that's my favorite part of the whole
[ __ ] night is closing my eyes and
being high
and the [ __ ] music the speakers
you know yeah that they're the
vibrations it's the natural that
activates your blood except for that
girl behind us like that girl made me
laugh so much because she was so
terrible like she's she was like the
comedian in the group but she was saying
awful jokes like kick him in the dick
and she she thought it was hysterical
doing an all like ha ha ha ha
the whole night every once in a while i
would look
she would get into my [ __ ] head
and i would look and i would just look
away like i didn't even get involved i'm
not a girl though
the worst thing you can do with those
things is mingle with people right
because once you mingle with them you
ain't going to shut them the [ __ ] up
i know this is known comedy yeah all
right what's your name whatever okay
just look straight and they'll get the
hint yeah don't get the [ __ ] hint
after two minutes listen i ain't here to
[ __ ] make friends okay i'm here to
watch the ufc you want to ask questions
not now ask them some other [ __ ] time
ask me by the bar but right now i'm
watching this but there's an attitude
you have to take
if not i'm sorry they'll keep [ __ ]
harassing your dog and he didn't he was
just drunk and he was a sweetheart of a
guy but that's a great fight what do you
want to talk about what do you want to
talk about now
what do you want to know what part
what matter what right now right now you
want to get biography or maybe she was
like how i am i'd like to like yell out
things to make men feel like they less
than when i'm watching them at sporting
events no really no yeah i like to like
what you call that like to belittle them
i'll be like yeah look at that ass your
ass so tighten them pants go on number
47 yes oh them balls just hit them in
the neck oh [ __ ] you shot that dick like
i like saying stuff like that no no this
is not sure it's crazy this is a white
event
he's a white and white people that dude
had a golden phone receiver over his
neck
he would point out people that were
dressed weirdly and he would just be
like what do you think his [ __ ]
smells like
look at this [ __ ] mook it was a guy
i mean listen those tickets that we had
were 1200 seats i know they sift people
out
i don't know what is this what do they
say
you know i think it's a thousand
yeah a thousand base
these people are not animals
so these four chicks paid eight hundred
dollars a ticket they came from whatever
hellhole listen
at 800 dollars a ticket if you want to
take your [ __ ] out
you're [ __ ] drilling it
i can't say nothing no
you know at those events unless you
break my air
there's nothing i could say because i
have the same but remember
but remember
that goes two ways
that i go i could do i could get dirty
and i could get stupid so when i start
yelling i hope your mother gets hit by a
train i hope you get cancer in your
[ __ ]
and you start crying because your aunt
lucille
died of cancer 18 years ago when i was a
little girl because you got three vodka
martinis in you
don't [ __ ] with me either
do you understand me that goes two ways
so i could fall into the game but me i'm
a professional i gotta achieve with you
with me i got voices in my head no
matter what
i'm watching [ __ ] get beat up
i'm thinking about the next move we in
and that dude gets kicked in the head
yeah the guy the uh john salmon
[ __ ] knocks this [ __ ] out
with a leg with a head kick beautiful
pain right from the book whatever you
need to do on the street whatever you do
for a living you want to kick somebody
in the head watch that [ __ ] footage
from last night that was the opening
fight that we saw then uriah faber and
then there was a little break and it
opened up with all those other guys we
saw the main car we were very fortunate
to go
uh
you know joe gets six tickets
uh but even when we got there there was
a guy sitting next to me you saw he
started asking me questions i thought
you knew that guy no i don't know nobody
oh you didn't know him no no no no no
no no no
i'm not there to take pictures i'm there
as a fan just like you hmm
why are you [ __ ] with me you know
what i'm saying why are you [ __ ] me
and the area was cool the dudes in front
of me were everybody was cool yeah the
chick they they shut the [ __ ] up after a
while i know it was they could not out
talk there's no woman that cannot talk
is it just me or does ufc fighting look
like right it looks like rape to me
it looks like man rape
it's like a different type of battle now
you know we evolved as human beings we
want to see more [ __ ]
in 30 years maybe we'll see
[ __ ] handcuffed and fighting
with with a knife that's what i'm
wearing it didn't feel like it did feel
like a gladiator thing like when i was
there it's very strong it's a very
people fighting to the death in grease i
was like oh and then do you remember
when that guy got kicked in the stomach
and you could like you couldn't hear a
lot of the punches but that it went
crack right in the stomach it was like
one of the last fights
maybe
that was a great fight i flew back this
morning with big john mccarthy okay i
flew back on the first flight as usual
[ __ ] it
6 55 like a [ __ ] out of it
get out of here yeah that's crazy [ __ ]
you i walked right through the whole
thing there was in the soul there
what did i get to eat
yogurt in the cup that's what i ate this
morning [ __ ] it i didn't want to go
too crazy we ate pretty nice how bad
were your farts last night all right
this morning i mean after the video hey
chicken dog no you eat yogurt yeah but
my fart that's tremendous it balances me
out the ph in my stomach
i eat chicken last night i didn't eat
was surprised no meat yeah
no i can't even mistake and then go to
bed that's not good tiffany
i don't know if you want to clog you not
for the clock [ __ ] makes you your body
work harder
at night you don't get a good night's
sleep i already had problems i already
got insomnia i'm already only going to
sleep [ __ ] three hours you know what
i'm saying yeah
what about that
that white soccer mom in the elevator up
to your room who you told to stay black
and you would know you would okay first
he was telling us
she drives like a lexus
suv
he's in there telling her a story about
a friend of his who has a tattoo above
her [ __ ]
and something like all these horrible
this is a gay dude oh it's [ __ ]
hysterical
this woman's just looking at him like
uh-huh uh-huh the lady walks listen we
get on the pla i get on the [ __ ]
elevator with lee i'm telling you the
illegals how do you know this guy go we
came up together at the comedy store
like well i love him like a sister i go
but she's [ __ ] nuts the girl's
compass is off
and in life sometimes a woman's compass
gets off yeah and you make three or four
bad men decisions
you really have to stop as a woman and
go do i continue this
let me take a year off a dick
let me get a vibrator a cat yeah i could
vibrate it with hair one that blows
grenades in my [ __ ]
and let me get my i got one with pearls
and let me get my compass back let me
get my female compass back one guy hit
me the other guy cheated on me the other
guy [ __ ] my sister i'm doing something
wrong that's what any normal human being
would say that
i could flip this around and being a man
if your first wife left you the other
one killed yourself and the other one
left you for [ __ ] louie
there's something going on we're not
doing something right i would i don't i
had those problems i know i understand
that's why i've been with this one for
14 [ __ ] years because you know when
you relate when my marriage didn't work
it destroyed my insides for a long time
not as a
whatever it may be more as a catholic
and a man in a way like how do you fail
in marriage yeah how the [ __ ] do you
fail this is easy you know why we fail
now because we married a [ __ ] we
meet at a casino right and he sucks our
[ __ ] right and we splash in his face
and this is my man no we didn't even
give this [ __ ] a chance after
he's gonna bring his mommy in next thing
you know you're working and he's
supporting his mom and you're like look
like
[ __ ] [ __ ] me good one time since
then he's talking about mommy that she
makes the best rice and beans and
whatever same thing flip side so we were
talking
we would talk we went one day to get a
bag of weed
and she asked me like a woman like
what's my problem i said here it is man
take a year off you gotta do nothing
i mean the last [ __ ] cheated on
you the one before that you checked in
his email
and the [ __ ] was when you were
working
he was
dancing for old dudes that was 60 years
old with panties on
and then it's not met
and your [ __ ] got his name on your
[ __ ] you understand me once you put
your man's
name on your [ __ ] and the relationship
goes sour
it's either time to see a counselor
see a [ __ ] doctor or get it to light
a candle kill an animal
sacrifice a [ __ ] do you
understand me there's certainly brothers
certain things that you do as judgment
now you take not even a year off move to
vegas and you marry a [ __ ]
that's gay
so
so we're talking about this show this
story the same exact words and then the
most
the why this woman comes in and you know
when these [ __ ] interrupting you and
you thought [ __ ] it you know what you
want to hear you got the balls to press
the [ __ ] elevator button let me drop
this
she looks at me like hi and we're like
let me tell you what i was telling my
buddy here we know this chick that
married a gay dude put his name on her
vagina and i broke it down just like
that and it's seven second elevator
seven seconds this lady looked at me
yeah
that's what was going on that's what was
happening
that's crazy wait you know a [ __ ] that
put a gay man's name on her [ __ ] not
not going that one wasn't gay that's the
one that was
emailing old guys going to the house
and putting on like super bad and then
you put money in his g thing then he'll
suck your dick maybe with a condom in
his mouth or or whack off you and the
old man has to sit there with his hands
on his side that type of dude why so
he's like gay but not gay right right
yeah it's like i'm just trying to get
money right here y'all try to support
the family i'm not bad i'll come over
take my clothes
it's easy work you can't [ __ ] touch
me
you can sit there whack off i don't want
to look whatever you do i'll dance
it's 22 a song what do you mean
last fact i came over here i paid them
12.50 to take 15 because my balls would
be clean
you know what at the end of each dance
i'll scratch my feet
right what the [ __ ] you gotta do what
you gotta do three four songs is sixty
dollars yeah
that's how you have to look at this one
of the craziest one
i've done last one
one of the craziest tv shows i worked on
was about weird couples and it was this
woman married to a dude who said he was
straight
but was doing gay porn and was trying to
like oh yeah she looked so sad she was
like telling her sister like no he just
does this to support us
and he this dude was so gay
and this girl looks so sad you know was
he getting banged in the muffler yeah
yeah so you have an accent and you're
living it what the [ __ ] the saddest
scene in the entire show
you know camming you know how girls can
go in front of webcams now
while he was webcaming and she needed to
get something out of the bedroom and she
was crawling on the floor on her hands
needs to get like something out of her
bedroom
while her husband's like jacking off for
guys on the
internet you know i love them so much
and i was just like oh my god oh how
does people fall for that listen
she's no self-esteem
i don't give a [ __ ] if you're [ __ ]
marlon brando
you're not gonna fake getting a dick up
the ass and say you're not gay okay
that's gay that's a commitment that's
fast gone done done that rabbit doesn't
die [ __ ]
yeah that's gay even if you put your
dick in somebody's ass well maybe not
the cubans that go to prison they have
that whole system i've discussed it
before with
they banging the muffler what and you
have to suck that dick but they don't do
nothing to you
and you have to act like a woman it's
like a prison thing i'm sure people do
it before that the first people wait a
minute wait a minute you have to act
like a woman these guys are married so
let's say me you and lee are in the cell
and you're a man
and i come in and i just start smacking
you and smack and leave [ __ ] you
[ __ ] and often i pay money and
i get two weeks in
and i make you and lee put on weights
and then i'll make you both of my freaks
right and uh
and i would and you would suck my dick
i'd [ __ ] you in the ass and you two lead
to
it only sucked my dick nothing else i
would not let you [ __ ] me in the answer
uh nothing you don't give us no hand
jobs next one you just you just use us
like buckets yeah we just little [ __ ]
buckies yeah
[ __ ] us
and every time i sit there and watch tv
you got to rub my shoulders
with your wig on twisting your [ __ ]
beard and make believe you're enjoying
it yeah and i'm sitting there like a
[ __ ] i'm like i'm running things like
you're a king and [ __ ] and guys come in
like with messages
you smack them and they fall down and
cry shut up
this and i look at you and i go this
will happen to you if you rub my [ __ ]
this will happen to you stop it
just out of manhood i'll smack you too
and then
what are you wanting man i am boss i'm
sorry i'm sorry to interrupt uh
white people are cutting them on
listen you go out there and you get my
[ __ ] message
and then while the black dude's fixing
his wig
you give him a message right
you tell him i said i'll [ __ ] around and
you smack the black dude's wig off again
all
right
get the [ __ ] out of here
suck my dick [ __ ]
isn't it crazy that that's your job to
think up stories like that yeah to get
super stoned and like come up with a
whole scenario where you're the mopping
of the cube in jail it's not that who
knows this could happen this [ __ ] is
probably actually happening this is
gonna happen in ebolaville
where is ebola in africa what the [ __ ]
do you think ebola villa is [ __ ]
belly hills where they first started
testing ebola jesus christ all right so
that's why they call it ebola wait why
are you gonna get me off to tell you
wanted to have that chibo chew now no
those three yeah that story brought to
you by auntie dolores and her cookies of
death how were they
how what are you high right now yeah
yeah he's fading look at him he's
starting to look asian why are you high
on the
animals are you yeah it was only three
milligrams no it wasn't you look like
you're about to pass out
go ahead and start rubbing your nipples
there you go
yes you would
somebody wait a second sorry that
definitely has we have to discuss
something yes so break this down to me
before
you never had your nipples up before
never
okay
yeah that's good now they suck your
nipples you play with your little cuban
no no what do you think you play that
like a [ __ ] mortal it it doesn't
happen that often but
one of the worst
online dates i went on this girl bit my
nipple like hard and made it bleed so
like
after that i would tell girls to get
away from there
he's getting away from there he's
bringing up put your mouth on my heart
now you enjoy it yeah it's okay she just
sucks them gently yeah and what happens
if you get a wreck do you sweat heavy
i'm not high enough to answer that
question no what happens to you just lay
there
no he does this what he's doing right
now turn red and get going
smile our hearts
just lay down because you're always
making fun of me you squeeze your
nipples and tell your lover what do you
do when she [ __ ] says
you just sit there like jesus laying
there with your arms out no
you can do something you smack that ass
right which you do i don't know what do
you do in that situation i don't know i
don't like my nipples sucked i just
don't like it makes me feel [ __ ] up
many man nipples it's man it's crazy you
just um
and then you try to look up at them in
their eyes
they like it
like that [ __ ] don't you yeah i didn't
think i would get it moist right now
thinking about it i didn't think you
would you like everything you're dirty
free no i'm not gonna like
you he always wants me to look at girls
[ __ ] and disgusting stuff would you
like sucking your little nippy yeah what
is so much like what's the you always
talking about looking [ __ ] what's
the deal with that
like what the [ __ ] it's a fantasy what's
so good about it though i mean it's
tremendous [ __ ] comes out of there no no
you wash it if you take care of that
thing yeah and you have like a loofah
and you keep it up every it's beautiful
a woman a woman's muffler
should not smell like nothing like that
i think mine smells like medicine or
whatever
i was like it don't smell like that it
doesn't say no it don't smell like that
you can't i've never been in a woman's
muffler where it's not like she just
took a [ __ ] dump
i never really had i don't know i'm very
very fortunate did you ever have a girl
lick your butthole yeah and i didn't
like it it's disgusting that sounds
terrible i'm too uptight for that [ __ ] i
talked that big game well i'm too
uptight i don't know
listen i know for a fact my asshole's
disgusting
i wouldn't describe your [ __ ] when a
woman sucks my [ __ ] i know that she's
doomed
yeah
if a woman doesn't look at me and
pre-judge it
she's doomed why would you suck my ass
okay a nice bald lick never killed no my
balls are nice i clean them but my
[ __ ] you're taking a chance that's
the way i look at it
i wouldn't go up to some chick
i would just look at somebody and judge
it i could tell what their [ __ ]
smells like you could tell by looking at
the jeans that's your favorite activity
we're sitting here we're sitting
there
and he knows his size too he's like
that's a fat [ __ ] and then oh my god i
love it
that's what you did this really tall uh
blonde girl walked by he's like her
[ __ ] is this small
yeah they got they're beautiful but
they're five eight and they weigh a
hundred pounds yeah when you go down
there's two hip bones oh that pushes
under the valley yeah and you hold on to
it and you lick it and there's nothing
there it's tight it's nice and it's nice
for a while but sometimes you want to
turn up the [ __ ] heater you know
i need some meat on you on your monkey
right
my ex told me that my [ __ ] tastes
like chicken
that's disgusting
as he said he's
he's like can i get some of that chicken
that's why he's your [ __ ] actually i
want to eat some of that chicken
it's really weird how you judge
you prejudge somebody sometimes
if you see a dude that weighs 500 pounds
you're not going to go i want to suck
his dick that's not the first thing you
got to think about neither with us no i
would think i want to eat dinner with
him but for some people they'll look at
that person and go she's hot lee likes a
spanish or a
sister that's got some meat on their
bums yeah when i was a freshman mm-hmm
all bats were off with me
like i was just a regular kid i i went
to school with white chicks though so
i'm like white chicks there's a couple
in the eighth grade like this puerto
rican chick from kennedy school
but besides that there was white chicks
in my neighborhood
but when i went to high school it was
mixed but there was a little sicilian
chick this little white
little chick with a little pat balance
our hairdo
this little freak walk by me
and i noticed something i noticed
i saw something that i had never seen on
a woman before
in in these pants on that particular day
i'm not meaning this in a weird way a
lot of women don't know this a lot of
young women listen to the podcast
her uh
it was like you look at the vagina and
you can see what's under there
it's kidding me if i like you it's not
even a camel toe
it's not a camel toe it's just shaped a
certain way
and with imagination you could just get
it
and so oh my god you can see through the
face beautiful
and i was in love with this girl i would
look at her i would go that g i was uh
freshening your geometry
i would go to that class
just to see what she would wear
what type of jeans and
and i never told nobody i would just go
to that class and i estimated at that
time
that her [ __ ] probably weighed 40
pounds
i would say
like no it's not 50 pounds but it's more
than three yeah yeah i fell in love with
this girl because of how she was packing
it there was a certain way 50 pounds it
was just meaty it never was a camel
though
it was always
how do you know it wasn't a penis
because you knew it was there because
years later we hooked up okay and was it
40 pounds it was tremendous
it was tremendous i don't understand how
do you put weight on [ __ ] i don't know
that's how perverted i was
that's how my mind you know
women look at guys feet women look at
guys hands women look at guys bulges
their ass women will go oh he looks kind
of dirty i know these girls one day that
were telling me stories there were two
chicks hanging out and they were just
telling me how they judge men
i look at their fingers their feet their
fingers their teeth
it's very seldom so they we also do it
but you don't look at a dude it looks
like you got greasy hair oh yeah if
you've got greasy hair in public you
know his [ __ ] ain't gonna smell like
[ __ ] lloyd to london
it's gonna smell like a [ __ ] death
rot my grandma always taught me dirty
fingernails if you got dirty fingernails
he got dirty dick just no no that's it
know that that's it
how are you gonna let that man stick his
fingers into your vaginal [ __ ] yeah
you're gonna get a yeast you're gonna
get something nasty
me i bite my finger but before i go on a
date i usually you know and when i was
younger i would nail file them i don't
want to hang them you got clean nails
though yeah bad fingers that's fat dick
no this is this is tremendous this is a
savagery [ __ ]
the head's very round
you're killing me you're killing me
but i'm a penalties but uh
just just
it's not it's not nothing uh i'm sure
any other young men did at the [ __ ]
age of 14. i just looked at it and i
just felt she had a beautiful face
she had a big ass but it was flat but
[ __ ] the [ __ ] was so tremendous i
overlooked the ass understand me what
about that one on that girl in the black
dress last night it was like the
the uh kardashian but it like was like
huge remember that big girl with a huge
ass last night
oh no she was no kardashian no no she
didn't look good she was no [ __ ]
cadet but it just went out and i'm
saying oh my god it was it was you know
you look at pete again you don't want to
judge but some people you look at las
vegas and go you don't belong to me
what are you going to do i feel about
that way about handicapped people in
casinos no no no no they shouldn't be in
casinos
you're already not lucky what are you
doing in the casino no no no no no i'm
talking about
chicks that you look at and you're like
why are you here
why are you here you got you're taking
down these three hot chicks these three
little hunches came for dick
and you're the [ __ ] what's that thing
with the ship throws over
you're the anchor that you're not going
nowhere because of you they're gonna
keep looking at you all miserable
that's it me and lee sat there by the
elevator at the end of the night
and we were just talking there was a
couple with a great tie and she had a
green suit on you reminded me i forgot
we were [ __ ] hot
we were [ __ ] high friday night i got
there
my flight was an hour delay it
definitely had
i had a burbank airport but between you
and i i didn't give a [ __ ]
because it was vegas i knew everything
was running late anyway i knew i when i
got that plane i knew it was going to be
a late it's never it's the last flight
of the day
if every flight is 10 minutes late it's
the same plane guys
it's like they're coming in from
somewhere else it just keeps going back
and forth picking up dropping them
picking up dropping off they shut down
at two then they start again at five
bing bang bang bang bang bang so [ __ ]
nine o'clock they don't fly in and out
of vegas i think you could fly into
vegas that's the last flight
8 35 is the last flight that flight took
off at 9 40. for [ __ ] 20 years i've
been telling lee
lee that flight's 35 minutes but after 9
11 they went the prices went up so they
couldn't justify it so they drive around
vegas a few times
and then often they say it took an hour
this [ __ ] lee how long i called
you at 20 to [ __ ] 10 and i landed at
10 11 31 minutes ten by like because i
was getting ready to come pick you up
and i was it was 10 15. you're like i'm
here i'm like jesus christ
because it's right down the street it's
right down the [ __ ] street bird bank
to [ __ ] las vegas yeah this mother
that was the first time ever they didn't
serve peanuts or soda they said no we're
running into turkey there's no
turbulence this [ __ ] said watch
this
watch my shirt and we're here watch my
[ __ ] i'ma break the record today 31
minutes
boom bumper the bumper today we got on
and the lady said it
she goes it's uh this is welcome to your
7 55 flight to los angeles
to burbank he's supposed to arrive at
nine this is a 40-minute flight boom we
landed at eight [ __ ] whatever i i got
to my doorstep at nine a.m what the [ __ ]
you think again
you just gotta know what time you gotta
find your limitations i got into vegas
at 10 30.
i took a cab to the hotel i checked and
everybody everything was easy for crazy
they picked us up we went over to the
[ __ ] uh south point south point to
have that dirty at 12 30 which ralphie
may put together that's what i'm saying
the ralphie may put that deal together
oh man so it's a big 300 people you
[ __ ] destroyed yeah the bar was
packed bar was packed tiffany had this
you'll [ __ ] those [ __ ] yeah i
will you'll be backing away saturday
morning that's what i said
so uh we went we met some people we met
my brother talking there yeah bad
[ __ ] i love jokingly me too he's
a nice [ __ ] kid he's a savage token
we didn't hook up with himself
no his name was larry and he no token
yep yes it is [ __ ] we don't
release names like that you know what
i'm saying the heavy duty you never know
who's listening man man
the government be all around
oh [ __ ]
it's monday get it together [ __ ]
you got i don't know how many days 15
[ __ ] days before christmas
16. yeah
well some mommies to pick you up little
tv wins
oh my heart my heart
no
we hooked up with what time five
uh six we had a cheaper chew we smoked a
half a number we went to the fights we
had nice seats thank you joe rogan
we sat uh
who else came my nephew yeah
and then joe's two friends and then
joe's two friends came which was cool
justin was cool as [ __ ] yeah justin we
watched the fights i got you out of
there before you got caught in the
[ __ ] crowd yeah because i took care
of your uncle joey so he told me when i
got there don't drink anything but i had
two drinks i had to pee i could see when
i told you i had to be
he was like he's never coming back
because he thought it was too long of a
walk but i came back right before the
last fight and you guys were like oh
we'll go to the bathroom and he kept
saying oh i'll be back for you and i
knew you weren't coming back first of
all
yeah yeah
break it down for you so you didn't come
back
down for the [ __ ] breath of many
units okay
first of all a lot of people know or may
not know the last week and a half
i was getting that uh i went swimming
the one time and then one time i went to
philadelphia and i laid down the tub and
i just took like a little nap and the
next day i had that [ __ ] when you spin
uh vertigo
vertigo
so i was a little nervous all week so
friday thursday i got to go to the
doctor wednesday set up a dizzy thing
so this dizzy thing you go in there you
stand on a thing it's like a ship
then you lay down and they just spin you
around with goggles on
before the test i didn't know i didn't
know it entailed
i had this weed it was it was a sativa
which never [ __ ] me up this new york
sour diesel
and i found and it was nice and dry like
i like it
but for this excuse me so the [ __ ]
test was at 12 30. this is 10 30 11
o'clock in the morning right
i need a quicker pick up i had mercy in
the morning i couldn't get high this is
my first high of the day you guys follow
me now you know
if you know anything about your
[ __ ] reefer that first one
that's the mac dizzy doozy right that's
the one that you need 30 minutes just to
recover from your creative juices
you get a little higher than usual but
sometimes you take a chance
sometimes this weed might be a lot more
than what you anticipated at 12 30 yeah
and this should take you to this
different level
i always like sativas to start off the
[ __ ] morning a strong sativa a sativa
that takes you over the top makes you
want to get out and [ __ ] see the sun
it gets you so high that you go out in
the sun that's that mind high that it
gives you right there you go but the
problem is when you go inside
that high becomes something different
lisa
so i smoked as a tv i get in the [ __ ]
car i drive over laurel canyon cut a
truck off
on the other side of cold water zip into
[ __ ] bv make a [ __ ] left a
right deep into the heart of bv
be it beverly hills
[ __ ] [ __ ] on [ __ ] right
make a [ __ ] make a [ __ ] right on
uh
whatever the [ __ ] it is
go all the way down to
the end of hell where it meets wilshire
and the other wilshire and the other
[ __ ] where you're [ __ ] you make the
wrong turn there san vicente
you're [ __ ] at eight in the morning
okay you're late to out [ __ ] you better
call up wherever your meeting going
let's make this for an hour later cause
i'm headed to [ __ ] huntington beach
by mistaken [ __ ] there better be a whale
and breakfast and [ __ ] your day is
[ __ ] up okay you best be paying
attention you better not be on the phone
because your [ __ ] will get [ __ ] up
i make the right
i go upstairs
i go to the same doctor that i've been
going since i had the ear infection i
walked in there they put me on a sit
down
during the sit down i asked her pete and
when i walk out of the pier you know
they give you the [ __ ] big key
yeah go to the bathroom and open on the
way back i'm like oh my god
i am [ __ ] zapped
yeah yeah i go in they got water with
lemons because they're white people they
got water with lemons and cups and [ __ ]
i start drinking like three cups of
water i'm so [ __ ] high
and there's a people magazine right i'm
reading the big amazing and this little
puerto rican dude look at my [ __ ] comes
out he goes joey jose come on in
and they sit me down they're trying to
break it down for me this really [ __ ]
happened tiffany has
and they go right down this thing and
look out the window now when i go into a
room if it don't have a window it should
give me anxiety
so they got a window and i stand on this
thing and you have to close your eyes
for 30 seconds and breathe and that was
cool dizzy but then they sat me down and
they put me in like a dentist [ __ ] at
the same time but they put these goggles
on my eyes
dog my [ __ ] got dark right
i was really stoned
because that's what your mind naturally
does when i was a kid i used to go to
planetarians in new york city and wants
the who and the yes and what you do is
you put goggles on and they play all
this [ __ ] and you see like stars but
they're playing music it was the same
thing to me so my eyes were closed
guys they kept saying please mr diaz
open your eyes
please mr diaz open your head
and i could see my eye through one of
the lens and i was so high it wouldn't
find the guy stand behind me and open my
one eye and finally goes that's it put
tape on it they put [ __ ] tape on my
[ __ ] eye guys
they put paper i can't believe they only
say come back not high no they knew
i even tell the guy my eye is open you
[ __ ] my eyes don't
stop what the [ __ ] my eyes open he's
like look at the tape
my eye would not open
my eye was doomed doomed
i gotta live in 40 minutes i drove home
oh my god so now i go to the ufc yeah
now you know i'm crazy did you know that
yeah i know that okay so i know you long
enough to love it
i had a cheap with you
and uh uh what what's the name of the
silicon brown
and we had some tremendous weed
and i blasted usually the quarter of the
so kind brown it kills lee
i blasted the whole so kind brownie the
half kills me i can do the course
i blasted a hole you want a piece of
cheap at you
sure let's let's go deep tonight please
leave at least sitting there going joey
you're holding i can't do it anymore you
could listen you're the [ __ ] catalyst
you're the backbone of the organization
so i [ __ ] uh
i i eat the so kind brownie immediately
i smoke a joint
on the way there i ate sixty percent of
this [ __ ] chiba she was seventy
percent
and i walked down the stairs and i'm
looking at these stairs and i'm going
this is how [ __ ] crazy reefer is and
life is and i know people go through
this i start saying to myself what if
i have to pee
and i'm going to walk up i get vertigo
oh [ __ ] in front of all these people and
i fall down the [ __ ] stairs lee
you don't know what kind of anxiety that
is like
you're walking into the amazing show
you're like what if i fall down and
don't happen oh my god lee that's all i
kept thinking about what if i fall in
front of all these [ __ ] people right
how [ __ ] embarrassing is this so i
sit down and it's cracking this is
cracking the energy is great but every
time these people applaud
i'm getting higher and yeah because
they're raising the vibration up in here
it's [ __ ]
and all of a sudden the [ __ ] thing
comes on now i'm also thinking about we
were so close that you really could see
the
cage but there was parts of the cage you
couldn't see so you were automatically
drawn to go up
dog when you go up i get vertigo and i
kept thinking i kept trying to take it
and you couldn't do that focusing on the
thing and then i had to pee like a
[ __ ] if you noticed i drank
water i kept it light i sipped that
water throughout the whole show i didn't
guzzle it like a [ __ ] gavon i usually
go through eight of those waters during
a [ __ ] three-hour fight they give
them to you for free right they give you
free [ __ ] it was free you gotta tip them
uh yeah well not yeah yeah
all you had to do was sip them they give
you hot dogs pretzels booze right or
like they charge you well you [ __ ] you
paid 800 or something dollars for this
oh yeah
you better come up right you pay them on
the bench well no well the there was a
mean waitress who just said like i can
get you one drink but you don't have the
ticket for free drinks or i don't know i
only had two drinks i never really got
drunk and high at the same time that was
interesting no you got first time
no i was higher earlier because we took
the i was so [ __ ] stoned
during the fights when pat is [ __ ]
pinned when petty submitted uh what's
his name melendez i was so high
at that [ __ ] point and i kept
thinking i gotta walk up those stairs
this is my time i gotta go behind people
and slow it up
because if i [ __ ] fall backwards this
is gonna be horrendously bad
you're gonna wipe out everybody my
anxiety was
mind-boggling it's like a rhinoceros
running
downstairs clearing that my anxiety was
mind-boggling i felt bad for the people
i felt bad for my friends i felt bad for
myself
embarrassed joe rogan embarrassed me
because if we felt backwards i keep
walking up the [ __ ] stairs right i
don't know nobody who's that little guy
he's yelling joey i don't know him he's
a [ __ ] he's some dude that staggered
on he was sitting there i don't know he
wants to take a picture what a shame i
mean you know what am i gonna do so
that's all i kept thinking about lee
yeah so after gilbert melendez fight i
kept thinking
what if now what if i wait for the other
fight to happen and i'm walking out with
2 000 people i fall
because if i got to stand there i'm
definitely going to get anxiety if i
have to stand there and wait you know
like one at a time
that was a great fight wasn't it yeah
if i had to do that all the way up to
the top i would have had anxiety and
fainted right there
that's why i left when i left and we had
a little bit he's so sensitive you
always
man i kept thinking that i was gonna
fall and get dizzy
that's a complete different game mama
when you don't know when this
[ __ ] is gonna hit you two weeks
ago i had it in philadelphia i woke up
one morning that [ __ ] don't come
knocking
you know vertigo don't come knocking
vertigo doesn't come with like a little
warning hey in 30 minutes your world is
about to get rough
i went to bed flying i was stoned as
[ __ ] i smoked a couple [ __ ] numbers i
went back to my hotel room i took on a
leave i drank a coffee
and i watched damn i'm gonna leave in a
coffee and we yeah that's a crazy
combination yeah and i watch some
television
that's a suppressant and uh
depress it's another dip suppressant in
a dinner whatever but i'm up i'm on the
road it's friday night i don't really
have to wake up saturday morning
depressed
so i'm going to get a little extra sleep
i don't give a [ __ ] about it two or
three you watch the law and order yeah i
didn't get a couple notes you put the
[ __ ]
earphones on you listen to youtube play
some old down i played chaka khan yeah
whatever the [ __ ] it is boom yeah there
goes your night i went to bed like any
other night at three in the morning and
at four i had to wake up to pee 5 30.
and my [ __ ]
when i got up my [ __ ] started spinning
dog
i fell backwards you don't know what the
[ __ ] cracking you don't know if you
ate something at the comedy club you
know for [ __ ] dosed you
you don't know you start breathing you
finally get up you have to turn the
light on there ain't no [ __ ]
light
you gotta go to the bathroom turn the
bathroom light on you take your dick out
and spin in the room the dick
spinning is terrible it's terrible you
breathe a little bit and it goes away
and you fall asleep
okay wait a minute this happens every
time you have to pee no no this just
happened
two weeks ago out of it never happened
it happened about five years ago when i
had an ear infection uh i went swimming
got sick and then went on a plane you
can't travel when you're with a cold so
i got an ear infection so that i was at
a gym one day and my [ __ ] got all [ __ ]
up i started hearing [ __ ]
and then two weeks i went to the san
jose and probably worked in san jose
improv uh-huh but the sound for example
i got that mccormick and schmitz i went
in there for the happy hour like a
puerto rican night
and they put me in a chair all the way
to the back guys
and i had the ear infection and my
hearing was off so i threw the
[ __ ] room off right
meanwhile i'm dipping my [ __ ] in the
clam chowder what what watching like a
dodger game or some [ __ ]
and i started thinking oh my god i'm
going to pass out
what am i going to do am i going to fall
here if i'm going to if i or am i going
to make it to the [ __ ] door
so i was getting anxiety about making it
to the door i would hate to pass out in
front of people i don't know
you know it's the truth what a [ __ ]
nice restaurant differently yeah
i don't know what the [ __ ] but do i love
tiffany so i don't i would never want to
put you people in that predicament yeah
that's why i was so that's why i had so
much anxiety towards the end
at the fight that's why well no but you
do that you you have to say you like to
leave early because yeah there was it
took like 30 40 minutes for that whole
arena to exit but you also had another
good idea because we had it it was like
three or four hours after the chipothew
and we got a hot dog and i wasn't gonna
get one because it was gonna be dinner
but then it was like three more hours
until dinner that hot dog was pretty
good no we hadn't listened i know the
timing i've been to a thousand those
[ __ ] fights yeah but i was so high
out there i was so
[ __ ] high
like that fight
i kept looking down
because i kept catching myself and i'm
gonna get
vertigo last week two weeks ago i was
playing with the baby and i picked the
baby up and i'm like this oh my god
thank god my wife was in the room i just
put it on the [ __ ] couch and i fell
to my hands and knees
listen this afternoon let me tell you
what happened what if your wife
i get off the plane i go home i play
with the baby they got to do some
errands
i sit there i get my week straight i get
the suitcase cleaned out i put water in
the sleep apnea machine i clean the mask
i do all that [ __ ] in the phone rings
and i recognize numbers my old coat
dealer and i love this [ __ ] i
still talk to them you know once a month
and he calls me he was like what are you
doing he goes listen to me a big favor
what's up
he goes make some calls for me to call
your boy see if i can put a [ __ ]
thousand dollars on the raiders
i go raiders really he was they gonna
[ __ ] san francisco up i'm gonna show
these [ __ ] what's cracking he
goes i just came back from up there
swing by i hooked you up and i'm like
now i'm all right he goes please call me
back i really want to [ __ ] bet the
raiders
see what the score was though i know the
raiders won the raiders blew him out
that's [ __ ] amazing i forgot to call
him back i called the kid the bookie the
[ __ ] phone was on message and i left
him a message and he never called me
back so i spaced it i spaced all my body
back 24 to 13. yeah oh wow and they're
right there i don't know that one's
going crazy out there one and something
yeah this is the this is this is my old
coke deal
mm-hmm she must have inside tips listen
to what i used to do i used to call him
up in the old days ten years ago i call
him up every sunday you know what's
going on
nothing nothing who do you like today
and they go really yeah you like see
like he called me back and he give me a
win and i talk him out of it
and i know you want to bet yeah and i go
what do you want to bet 200.
and i go right i'll call you later and i
call him back and i'd sit on the bed and
he'd lose
and i wait two days ago we didn't get
paid in cocaine
he never figured out every week he lost
i think one time he [ __ ] won how
crazy is that mm-hmm
so this [ __ ] we do tiffany had issues
look at you a beautiful woman
let me get some showers we got to talk
about something yeah let's shout out
what's up lisa you bad [ __ ]
47 floating 747 i love you rusty cole
tommy p corey leighton
thomas cardwell and ryan know stay black
[ __ ] suckers
i love you to death what else lee tell
me something good
you haven't said much today you're
sitting there like a mook i need tell me
what happened
to you yet yeah these chocolates are
[ __ ] blinking like a pretty ass
they're [ __ ] me up we haven't had any
divorce in a while i know she sent us a
box i want to give a shout out to auntie
laura sent us a box
we're gonna do uh hanukkah the right way
this year we're gonna light them in
harmony and had a lot of respect for the
jews because we don't [ __ ] around here
we've been wanting to do this for years
no i haven't you know we we didn't want
to he didn't want to do the 30 30. he
said so let's do one better let's
celebrate your people let's eat a
[ __ ] edible every night from the 16th
to the 24th out of respect we'll light
the menorah what we'll do is we'll
[ __ ] i'll unwrap the edible and we'll
throw it in a
yannick or whatever move popping in a
yannick
[ __ ] like a tan like what you call
those things like a trampoline
a
yeah
it's like a trampoline
listen disregard yarmulke looks like
fried bologna to me you know what the
[ __ ] i'm saying okay what i'm saying is
we're gonna eat an edible for eight days
straight that's the least we could do
for it for that's the least you could do
for the church or what's happening now
you're a soldier well that's why i have
you insurance where's that chiba do you
ready to eat a little piece of cheap
yeah you know i said you told me like
five minutes ago and you said you were
gonna pull it out what are you gonna do
tomorrow you got nothing you got the day
off tomorrow
you got nothing to do tomorrow but sit
down put pressure on him when i said i
want himself because he i mean damn joey
he needs a piece look no he don't he's
gonna be sleeping on me he's not looking
good tonight
so
the reason why you're on this show i got
gotta be as honest i've known you for a
long time that part but i didn't see you
i don't really see you you know i don't
be seeing you i know you do spots at the
lab factory hollywood a lot
i see your name at different clubs and
then about
a month ago i go to the live factory in
houston
and it's in long beach one of my
favorite places in the world i love
performing there too i love long beach
you know why because there's no drama
you get there you know where you stand
every time i go to hollywood i gotta
park the [ __ ] car
i got to walk in they're doing 30
minutes behind there's street people
want to bump you you went through all
this [ __ ] [ __ ] to get bumped at
this age
yeah come on that's tuesday night [ __ ]
yeah it's thursday night come on jamie
you come on i love jamie at least he
hooks me up you know all i gotta do is
call the [ __ ] i mean this guy
went from not liking me no he's giving
me spots waiting
so i go to the live factory i'm sitting
that stone sometimes you sit in the lab
sometimes
and you know what you're forced like i'm
very happy to be back at the comedy
store because now i'm forced to watch
live comedy
listen guys i know that this comedy show
is on television
and we all have dvds and video specials
and the whole thing
i love watching a good hbo special i
came up on hbo special
the way they shoot it everything about
an hbo special i've always liked from
and we all have the different
generational gaps
which we like whatever period you know
i like the young comedian stuff i like
the the hicks stuff at those years the
kenneth and stuff on hbo
i like all that you know everybody like
you may like the newer stuff sarah
silverman or bill burke i don't know if
he's on hbo and you might like uh
whatever the [ __ ] you like i don't know
i like everybody everybody so
we all have different [ __ ] tastes so
for me an hbo special is it but i gotta
be honest here there's something about
watching a comic live
let's say you like let's say you like uh
tiffany
and
you know what what the [ __ ] do you do
with your time
i'm not being a kid and following a band
you know
for a couple months
and really on the other side you just go
out one night and if you go to l.a clubs
and you go out four nights a week you're
gonna see a lot of the same comedians
and some nights they're gonna go up
there three nights in a row they're
gonna go up then do the same [ __ ]
stick
and you may like them and not dislike
them
but you know what other nights you're
gonna see something else come out of
them
you're going to see this soul come out
something that with me only used to
happen at the comedy store that's why i
know how powerful the comedy story is
and it comes from doing a lot of sets at
a certain club over and over again
mm-hmm you're doing a lot of sets and
after a while you just get so
comfortable and every once in a while
your mind drifts like you just go
somewhere
and some nicely
you tell a joke man there's something
about that joke that might get them
but some nights it's the way you deliver
that job yeah that just destroys that
room
and it's maybe putting your foot out and
bouncing
or living that [ __ ] you just let
your body go and the audience feels it
because me as a comedian i feel it
and when i feel that from a comic
that's when you know that person become
a comedian
for years i went up there and just told
jokes and i'm like oh he's so funny
where does he get those
but it did took 15 years to click on to
get
a certain confidence a certain believing
i was scared shitless the other night
at that south point
i didn't want to go up that's the last
thing i'm going to do is go up at 12 30
at night in front of 300 [ __ ] real
people that you can't go up there with
l.a jokes right yeah you know like that
strips jokes and you go up there
so i did this film one time with
jennifer lopez and then she slipped
right and they're like jennifer lopez
it's friday night at 12 [ __ ] 30. i've
been dealing with [ __ ] asian [ __ ]
playing ping pong
over there at the golden nugget i want
to [ __ ] laugh okay right and you come
over here and you're up there no you had
a brilliant i opened up with some dirty
[ __ ] and it was kind of weird and i
remember before i left
i said i'm doing my bits tonight
i'm gonna have enough confidence in my
bits tonight mm-hmm
and i went up and did my bits and i did
perfect
i did what i was supposed to do because
i had a plan i knew where to take it i
was gonna [ __ ] with them a little bit
but i had seven or eight minutes i know
if i took them there and sold it
at 12 30 you got to commit jack they got
a feeling oh [ __ ] this guy's bringing 8
30 type of [ __ ] to the show because if
you go up there and do your same let
if you go up there and do a 12 30 show
they're gonna feel a 12 30 show that's a
disaster you got to give him an 8 30
show that was what was in my mind i had
to wake him up a little bit late
i had to flip them about that energy is
the whole thing you know you know what's
crazy i i'm not usually a huge fan of
like the 20-minute sets as a comedy fan
going to the club i like a headliner
more but you're one of the people who
actually like that 15-20 minute set was
crazy that was perfect because during an
hour you would have to slow down a
little bit you'd have a heart attack but
you just didn't stop for like 20 minutes
i'd rather pound you i want to pound you
my style is to pound you
you know but to take it back a couple
weeks ago when you do sex in l.a i go to
the comedy store
every four or five people you see
somebody who gets into a different place
and they deliver
and that's what i mean a couple weeks so
i saw you go there and you went there in
between bits
and you had gone there one time
and i was like look at tiffany havish
bring a different type of heat and i
didn't say it until you came back and
then you went to bring me up
and i was sitting there
and i was enjoying tiffany so much that
i didn't want to go up
that's when you know that's when you
know
you
there's a difference between
somebody doing good and you being
jealous of them
there's a difference between somebody
doing
good and you being scared to follow
but there's a difference between
somebody being in front of you
and they're doing so well they're not
threatening you
but you're feeling them so much you
don't want them to get off the stage
you're enjoying it i'm living it i'm
living she was telling anything about
grandma that the [ __ ] is your house you
got to keep the bushes true you got to
keep it clean but she became her
grandmother yeah or whoever character
she might be doing because sometimes
you're thinking grandma is there
this is my ass sherrell yeah but i can't
tell the audience that because they're
not going to understand sherrell i just
talked about my aunt bonnie and i'm
gonna confuse these [ __ ] i
don't want them to think so grandma just
cleans it up right grandma cleans it up
you have to commit to the name just
grandma and it was really weird that you
took me there and i go you know what i
got to get around the podcast because i
want her to know
that you're there
thank you and you're hiding you're
hiding they got you hidden you're liking
the witness relocation plan that part
you gotta get you gotta get with the
agency that push your sisters to just
drop you in them and i know you're at
the right agency you make the movie a
ball with the same [ __ ] up
but you're like in that shuffle right
now you're next i'm yeah transitioning
up to the top of the deck of the cards
you're next year ready let's go you're
like renee zolwiga before
that movie you know she was at the
laundromat she was out of quarters
and she got the call from tom cruise oh
yeah that's the call that you always
wait for when you're out here
and not because you sucked this dick but
because you auditioned eight times again
and the last two times were in front of
that [ __ ] right before they give
you those type of movies that you got to
go with tom cruise they got to shoot you
from this direction that direction make
sure you're tall you're not taller than
him with heels make sure you can run
next to him and you're smaller than him
so you got to go to 19 auditions
and then read with him because everybody
wants to make you know he's getting 20
million in the movie he's going to want
to come out of the shadows very seldom
that i have to read with somebody but
every once in a while there's a
[ __ ] room without you know it
which throws a [ __ ] left wrench in
your [ __ ] head yeah that's amazing
when you go in a room and you know
somebody's in there you're like
that's it and you go up and you have
that paper in your hand and your hand
starts shaking yeah because you're so
nervous
oh my god
and you'd be feeling like oh my god am i
[ __ ] up right now i don't care i'm
just going to live this life i'm just in
this slice of life right now i'm just uh
i'm just a prostitute and then you give
up yeah and then halfway through just
like the question you say you know what
[ __ ] it you're already thinking about
your next role well ralphie may say he's
pokemon take me on tour and at least say
he's gonna put matter tonight
and also you just click it on
and they even say hold on one second do
it again from the start now you got
something yeah i'm taking this
[ __ ] somewhere even though i
[ __ ] up he knows it he was there he's
a real actor they're not going to throw
yali right if they're real they're going
to go let him read it again he showed
some and now you get it together you
close your eyes you take a breath you
think of your [ __ ] family while you
got there you think how you want to
sling dick and bam you put that
[ __ ] down in front of whoever
the [ __ ] starts talking he goes
let me get in there with you
and you actually start reading the first
time you're nervous the second time you
start rocking and rolling and then you
get something out of him and everybody's
laughing you close you win the scene you
know what i'm saying even though it's
not on paper you have to think of
something this is where you're a
comedian this is where you but butting
up the room button up the [ __ ] room
bam
leaving with something to smile about
tell them what your name your [ __ ]
serial number is and you just keep
walking [ __ ] let them go what
was that spirit that just won
what yeah they always tell me oh you
were a breath of fresh air we know you
weren't right for the part i mean blonde
hair blue eyes but it was just great to
have you here today you're refreshing
now when did you get on stage the first
time
um in 1997
where at the laugh factory no [ __ ]
1997. yep i'll never forget it because
that because i got on the news and
everything but princess diana had died
and bumped me from the news and then i
didn't get to get my my segment showed
until i went back to school
and then when did i meet you
you met me in 2002
2003 no [ __ ] yeah i met you 2003.
no 2004 because then we were standing
outside of 2005. yeah i met you in the
office first at jka and then i would
bump into you know i always heard you
were struggling because sometimes like i
said you bump into people
and also one day you go out to do spots
and you go where am i stepping out
and then a year later you're taking the
train and this tiffany house with would
have kidnapped
didn't when we together at the live
faction you were taking them to the top
you had a deal at the [ __ ] brad pitt
company like yeah well the deal fell
through james mason did this but nelson
i got married got a kid i live in
[ __ ]
west hills now and with a bunch of
that's not my story no and not at all
that [ __ ] she must be talking about
somebody else yeah no i kept hearing
about that
cause i got married you know i got an
awesome i would just hear little things
about tiffany from other [ __ ]
additions
that's it that's what i'm saying that a
lot of [ __ ] give up
right you didn't give up i meant in
2005. you only had a couple years under
you yeah you know most pretty girls this
the [ __ ] up here
i i hear that that's i've seen it now
over the years i'm like i'm noticing it
but like i remember when i first met uh
corey holcomb he was like baby girl you
need to just give up on this you don't
need to be no damn comedian you need to
just go meet you somebody rich there's
too many rich [ __ ] out here you
a pretty girl just get pregnant you know
get pregnant by a rich dude maybe get
two or three rich baby that is and just
call it a [ __ ] day because it's
comedy you ain't built for this you
ain't ready to let you ain't gonna last
through this
like
and now he sees me now it's like 11
years later he's like yo i'm sorry i got
a bunch of reasons you're doing it yeah
i'm proud of your respect for you man
you know i think uh women have to work a
little hard and i hate that slogan
you're a [ __ ] comedian yeah i'm a
comedian
now i hate when they be like are you
ready for a female no how about are you
ready for a funny [ __ ] are you
ready for a funny comedian how about
that
yeah it's really uh because i could have
a penis in a drawer last five years
you've heard little things from people
uh
just jerkoffs i mean i say a lot of
crazy things but mm-hmm
that's just jericho would say women
aren't funny yeah and all i have to say
to them is who the first person to make
you laugh yo mama lucille your mama and
my mama yo mama was the first person to
make you laugh think about it or was you
just not a giggling baby you just didn't
laugh at [ __ ] that's [ __ ] all of us
laugh first person make you laugh is
your mama so what you saying if women
ain't funny your mama ain't funny [ __ ]
you suck my dick that's pretty uh that's
how i feel about it that [ __ ] makes me
my mom used to make me laugh but lucille
ball took me there
lucille ball took everybody there unless
you're a [ __ ] mormon
once your ball made everybody laugh so
for a statement like that to come out
that woman aren't funny in general even
if you just said yeah most women aren't
funny lucio ball was funny yeah i'll
respect you then but you're not giving
laughs to nobody you know you're just
saying in general so that's always been
a stupid statement me i don't give a
[ __ ] i'm not gonna argue with you on
facebook what do i give a [ __ ] what
difference gonna make with it i'll argue
with you
i never know you like lucille ball so
much
lucy is this [ __ ] you know she's great
but like you were like really
do you know that lucy started out as a
dramatic actress she was an actress and
a singer first just a dramatic actress
and singer and then she got like by a
fluke got a role in a comedy and killed
that [ __ ] and they just started giving
her more comedies and then she started
buying up studios buying up projects
like boom get me radio superstar
she the [ __ ]
she it's not that i'd like to
how can you not watch those shows i
don't know how many episodes there was
but how can you not watch any of those
shows and not have two favorites
that you don't sit there or laughter the
ones with the cake the chocolate ones
with the pizza the chocolate the
sexaholic moccaholic yeah
you know there's six or seven maybe
three like when she tried to be like a
dancer one of his background dancers
whenever she would do that i love that
ricky was the [ __ ] yes you know ricky
was the [ __ ] let's figure listen i
didn't remember if he did a whole thing
on him delirious yeah ricky ricardo
that's 1950 a spanish dude on your tv
stop it
stop it with those pointy shoes with my
[ __ ] [ __ ] crazy white [ __ ]
crazy white [ __ ]
guys
and they ended up [ __ ] making studios
you know when you go to miceli's in
hollywood that's where they did the
famous pizza scene
where she's throwing the pizzas up they
wrote it right there on the street right
michelle's right [ __ ] there lucio
ball
stood there so for me how can you say a
statement like that
and she owned half a paramount yeah
like but it was just uh
i laughed at the lady who just died
she said some [ __ ]
joan rivers oh my god she's hilarious
when i was a kid when i'm a kid
she went off on prince's girlfriend
apollonia
one of those hoes she was one of the
tonight show she said to her that one of
those you like prince he makes michael
jackson look like a green beret
you know i liked her i remember that
stupidity those little jokes
god knows how many women i've thought
that are just
you know for
to me i like that when a woman makes me
laugh that's attractive
sometimes when i hear it's only happened
like three times the last couple of
years where some jerk off has written
his hand and said that
but i could just imagine they say
something like that about god guys ain't
funny whatever the [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ]
about these people what do they know
right how hard it is to be a prayer you
got married since i last saw you
divorced because for a while you were
living [ __ ] 80 miles from me yeah
cause i got married and he tried to move
me away he's trying to take me away from
my art he thought i was gonna quit
he's so stupid
i love talking on the microphone i love
being in front of people it's my
medicine it's my everything it's
it's will save my life i feel like like
it gave me a voice it made me feel like
you know people care
and even if they don't give a [ __ ] it
makes me feel good as [ __ ] and i'm gonna
keep on doing that until i die it saves
you in a way yeah
it gives you hope even when you're in
the beginning of it and you're [ __ ]
doing creepy [ __ ]
you're hooking up with i used to wait at
night to see who would lose their
[ __ ] phones at the comedy store
i would sit by the thing and people go
hi
i just found this in the chair and then
we're [ __ ] the guy at the door would
take it and put it right under here and
he would step out and i'd go back there
and take the [ __ ] phone
and sell it the next day for 45 bucks on
crenshaw boulevard for some black dudes
that years later ended up robbing a bank
wow and they're laying they all got
arrested and they closed the store
they used to hang out at the comedy
store
you have no idea you have no [ __ ]
idea lisa how do you find like when you
have a phone how do you find where to
sell that like how did you end up with
that guy okay there was a guy
there was a black dude in the early
2000s at the comedy store that was the
real deal
and he was he was somebody sugar daddy
like one of those black comedians that's
badass i just forget what her name was
he was one of those sugar daddies
and he would hang on we became friends
we were giggling he was old school from
like
either detroit or chicago one of those
black cities but they're real black
you know they're real black real urban
but he was really a gangster
and he did things like i forgot what the
i don't know if he gave his blow
he liked a friend of mine he was friends
with a friend of mine and we met
and he told me he was in the cell
business and i asked him like what are
you doing he goes i buy and sell them
which we know somebody was going to sell
from that's what i needed to hear
so i would just wait around at night at
the comedy store and then those weeks in
those days three people a week would
turn in cell phones
and i would call him and either come get
him i would drop him to cranshawn
charlie give me a hundred bucks
that's the side
and they have money on a friend but
years later they robbed something they
were producing comedy shows
and one day i asked around there was
cops at the comedy story what's going on
they go they're here because that dude
robbed the bank and got away with it but
they're looking for the money they got
away with like 18 million dollars so
they threw them in jail for contempt
something [ __ ] these guys got away
with it
they weren't just little [ __ ] black
dudes on roller skates they're not
stupid
they had it planned they were like
professionals at this [ __ ] so it's just
you never know who you're going to meet
man you know you've never seen a black
dude on a roller skate well it's because
you're slipping [ __ ] sucker that's why
black blue should always be on rollins
get it together get it together you're
slipping and [ __ ] yeah whiteboard now
you've been in transition
and you've been shooting a bunch of
movies right you've been going to
atlanta yeah shooting movies shooting tv
shows you're in this new chris rock
movie no
he don't know about you yet yes he does
he knows who i am
he knew about this haddish but i wasn't
willing to do it
was called four and the same i just i
didn't feel comfortable with that scene
did you go to read for it yeah i went to
read for a couple of roles in it and
then um they said they wanted me to do
this where these like ratchet girls or
whatever which is cool i could play
ratchet but i just couldn't do the part
where like um
yeah i just didn't want to i don't even
know if it's still in the movie or not
but in the script it was very
um not cool with me
you know i don't want no white stuff on
my face on camera
okay and that's it
but i think he's great
it's a great listen it looks like it's
gonna be super hilarious yeah it looks
good he's got everybody in there doing a
couple of days
i've always liked chris rock
but you get into the black market you
know sometimes you get in with the guy
with atlanta which you did yeah tyler
perry yeah i'm doing a series with him
uh a drama you gotta start somewhere and
then you branch out into the white
markets whatever nothing wrong with
being on bt i know [ __ ] will
give you a finger to be i love to be on
the show on bt as a [ __ ]
co-sponsor or something jumping up and
down dropping it from the center yeah
i'm on that real husband's hollywood
with kevin why are you really hungry
you don't [ __ ] around this is what i'm
talking about no i'm out here working
i'm always trying to do something i just
created my own little talk show called
two and a half women where it's me my
psychotherapist and my little dog she's
a motif yorkie mix she a white [ __ ]
that's the half and so it's two and a
half women and yeah we just be talking
about stuff that's going on in the world
like booty injections like what's really
going on why is [ __ ] burning their
ass out to have ass that ain't even like
all that like dudes don't even really
give a [ __ ] like you said about the girl
like her ass was flat but the [ __ ] was
tremendous right so like just focus on
what you do god [ __ ] you got no cheeks
with fat lips work them [ __ ]
you know the first thing i noticed i
went to vegas did they were beautiful
women
okay now i'm married i'm not looking at
a woman to [ __ ] them besides i'm humble
i'm bad it wouldn't matter i wouldn't i
just look at you now just to look at you
because i'm a [ __ ] man
and i look at women and they get
gigantic tits and they walk past me
and they got the worst [ __ ] ass
you've never seen your life it's like
going out
have you been to atlanta it's like going
out washing your [ __ ] but not brushing
your teeth
i've done that a few times going on and
you know like doing dumb [ __ ] i don't
i'm an ass man but i
look at me
if you were missing a hip i'd still eat
your [ __ ] half of it
you know but it's like it looks weird if
you don't have faith it's balance it out
yeah what's the matter half the tit you
know i want to look half of it i want
you know
i like a pretty woman
what's that chick from blue bloods
the chicken tom brady dump to be with oh
yeah gizelle you know tom brady would be
oh yeah
the white chick mowing the hat oh look
at that [ __ ] that [ __ ] is a top-notch
model she was in uh the bar with the
movie about the the bar with the chicks
dancing on the bar not a coyote ugly
yeah she was in the movie will smith she
plays the [ __ ] martian chick
you know but you know what i like about
it the most
she got little titties
me too yeah i got little titties in a
nice
but you know i like what you like the
most i like women when they you're
telling me something
you're making a statement you're
believing your face and your ass and
your [ __ ] you didn't bail on your [ __ ]
you didn't put it all up here like this
you know when you're out at a bar or
something when you especially when
you're young we get overpowered by a
chick who rubs her titties on you
there's a woman when the chicks are run
away
and she's trying to get attention her
tits get there first
you know if they show them to you so you
got tits it's their [ __ ] weapons of
mass destruction you know they rub it up
and you're [ __ ] dog and as you get
older you're like come on you can come
up with a blood trick that magician oh i
always like to um try to get it get get
to lick if i can get a good conversation
and where i can lick a guy's cheek then
i'm i usually win by then oh jesus
christ
yeah if i can lick a man's cheek i'll
usually win at that point i'm getting
whatever i can't see we got a blackhead
on his [ __ ] cheek you wanna lick his
[ __ ] cheek now yeah if i lick his
cheek that's it you don't wanna and if
they let me get that close to where i
can lick that chicken i know i'm winning
that's a different attractive to me when
i see a woman with a beautiful face i'll
be like damn look at you baby and little
tits what's that that really attracts
like little titties it's not that i like
to get my little titty up no it's not
that it's what's that i mean come on
it's not that i like them suck my
titties i suck yours no no it's not that
i like them you know what i like about
the situation that you're telling me i
didn't go get fake tits just to make me
look beautiful no it's a different type
of beauty you're telling me so i dig it
that's what yeah i said yeah my soul is
sexy i'm not saying if you want me to
look more beautiful i could take all
these clothes off if you could pay all
my bills
you're paying your own bills right now i
know yeah
you're making it happen [ __ ] beyonce
showing up with that [ __ ] baby you
know what i'm saying later on to try to
get more money out of it making bad
music too what are you talking about
that music is good i'll be jamming
outside like on the run but when the
[ __ ] does she ever go on the run
she robbed the [ __ ]
thought never her but she robbing our
pockets every day
was she trying to be a bonnie and clyde
stop stop i mean
i'm comply i have no idea what what just
happened i don't know what happened do
you think they're like my girl what just
happened where you at next weekend next
weekend
where am i i'm probably gonna be at the
live factory
yeah it'll be a live factory and when
you go to where you're gonna be for new
year's performance oh i don't know i
don't have new year's books right now
new year's is open so i'm probably gonna
be at the live factory but you know i'm
gonna be for christmas though i'm gonna
be all up in england and stuff because
you know i'll be meeting these fine ass
dudes that we want me to be places and
[ __ ] and get this money with me so i'm
about to go to london england from the
22nd to the 29th out there showing these
these london englanders how we get down
in south central los angeles yes sir
boom
no i'm gonna be dancing but it's the
same thing though cause it's gonna be
hilarious
what kind of [ __ ] dancing you doing
break it down for me knock it off before
dancing i'm doing a bar mitzvah
stand up
i'm dancing i'm a energy producer
i didn't know
are you putting me on no i've been an
energy producer for it like since 1996.
this is another felipe
felipe what are you talking about now in
my life on the sunday night
first you show up with the [ __ ]
angels
then you're eating a [ __ ]
cheeseburger now you're telling me
you're going to be an energy producer
yeah i produce energy that's what i do
you felt the energy when i walked
through the door it was like oh energy
that's what unicorns do and i do bar
mitzvahs i've done it for over over
15 years
i'm the last black unicorn all right i'm
a magical creature
you catch this bliss you win it you
understand me
you can only you can only succeed in
life if i'm your friend
there's no way you can be a failure
unless you [ __ ] me over
period
that's why i love them
i love you too but i'll give a shout out
to sponsors all right let's shout them
out first of all my favorite people of
all time these people are looking after
your [ __ ] back
uh alpha brain i don't know what else to
tell you you're firing all cylinders i'm
going back on my [ __ ] alpha brain
tomorrow cycle because i'm shooting a
film i don't want my mind [ __ ]
slipping at all
it's just this nootropics it makes your
mind
it's got a bunch of right now i'm too
high to break down the formulas of your
memory joe rogan takes them before the
ufc so yeah off some like it helps i
don't know what joe rogan right now i'm
telling you how it [ __ ] makes me feel
even though i smoke 82 000 bung it's a
day it clears me up it gives me more
words and gives me more focus and where
can you get it you have to go online and
get them you go to on it.com and the
beauty about [ __ ]
strong uh
alphabet your brain is it's got 100
money-back guarantee they just did some
type of exclusive testing in the
university of college in boston right
boston
and this thing came back that it helps
not glaucoma
alzheimer's this is how good and how
much is it who the [ __ ] knows
calm down on it exactly what size you
want if it don't help you if what it was
saying don't do it for you you get 100
money back guarantee we don't even want
the product back go to hunter.com and
press in church boom and get ten percent
off you order listen you're gonna love
it just stay on it go to stay on it.com
and get another 10 percent off and it
gets delivered right to your house every
month and don't stop [ __ ] there right
they got some tremendous stuff strong
bone and icm juice and and weights and
just kettlebells
and they just got battle rovers they got
some tremendous stuff also a beautiful
shout out to my main man over there on
[ __ ] irondragontv.com
my main man was here the other night
dave foley dropping for you i didn't
know what was going on they're talking
this [ __ ] i don't understand it all i
know is this i got a bunch of emails
that people went on and they love it
people love it you get two free
kung fu classic films they got the the
the the the the assassins the thieves
they got 1911 jackie chan the man series
they got so many classic films and they
had more daily
go to iron irondragontv.com and press in
joey boom what do you got lee two free
rentals two two two there ain't nothing
like going home smoking a few bungets
taking your socks off cutting your
fingernails or your toenails sniffing
your fingers
sitting back and watching that kung fu
movie nothing like it people don't do
that no more in america you don't
understand what you're missing a whole
classic kung fu movie go to
irondragontv.com they're going to rock
your [ __ ] world and stay with them
this is nanotech they're making [ __ ]
things happen this ain't the beginning
of what they're doing they're doing
something with music they're doing a
bunch of good [ __ ] trust me i wouldn't
be [ __ ] with them i don't think they
could help you out number two
boom nailed it life.com throwing heat at
you [ __ ] the exclusive vapor
pen of savages like lee cyan when he's
doing all his [ __ ] magic tricks go to
nailed it life.com right now look at
what they got they got everything from
t-shirts but their main thing are these
vapor pens they break you call david you
tell him that the filter broke boom
within 24 hours you got your [ __ ] up and
running go to nailed it live.com and
press in joey diaz ooh and what do you
get 20 off 20 [ __ ] percent off
okay nailed it live.com now what we're
talking about e-cigarettes i ain't
messing with you people it's december
7th
everything happens
everybody in this country makes these
[ __ ] things we call them reservations
resolution resolutions
and they say you know what i'm going to
stop sucking dick i'm going to stop
smoking cigarettes i'm going to go to
the gym and stop eating better you know
what start right now a lot of people are
smoking they don't know how to do to
start smoking three four years ago when
my wife was pregnant with mercy i know i
couldn't smoke i had to quit
thanksgiving i just started one day
smoking uh
cigarettes hitting cigarette regular
vapors i don't even know what the [ __ ] i
was smoking i quit never had a cigarette
again but i knew i quit
by smoking a vapor pen just to give me
the same
stuff you know i did what they do and
now they sent me uh some vapor pens that
are just tremendous they're the best
i've ever tasted a hitti six
twelve hundreds okay let me tell you
something they last longer and they
taste tremendous let's say you wanna
quit smoking you get the zero the eight
the 16 to 24 milligrams stop to the top
and work yourself backwards you got no
nicotine boom you're not smoking no more
your lungs feel better you can last next
or two minutes when you're [ __ ]
sucking and banging you can run up a
[ __ ] hill now that all happens when
you quit smoking cigarettes but it all
starts with 86.com they last longer they
taste better they got cigars they got
different cigarettes they have different
flavors you want to smoke mentor you
want to smoke raspberry boom go to
86.com right now see the whole [ __ ]
collection from this tremendous cigar
check this out you're going to be out
new year's eve you want to mingle with
your friends you don't want your fingers
to smell like dick
how do you spell that headheathsegs.com
here at e6.com right now and what do you
get you press joey's church and you'll
get 20 20 off try them give them a shot
for the holidays give yourself a better
life take care of your lungs trust me
stay black tiffany had it you're a
badass [ __ ] i love you to death thank
you what's up did you bring soda a
milkshake what did you get oh i have
some pink lemonade
pink lemonade because i like it i like
lemonade keep me posted on all your
successes you're [ __ ] beautiful i
will well but before we go can you tell
me what was the name of that first one
again with the mind pills alpha alpha
brain
dot com on it dot com honor dot com yeah
o n i t dot c
o n n okay that's why i couldn't find it
now you know what she didn't let
oh [ __ ] it's tremendous
oh [ __ ] she's taking it to another level
read the [ __ ] violent one let's wrap
this [ __ ] listen have a great
monday have a great week i'm shooting a
film this week i don't know if we're
going wednesday or thursday i'll keep
your [ __ ] posted i love you
have a great week tiffany had us thank
you yeah lisa had a great time on
twitter
you bad [ __ ] stay black we got a
tremendous guest this week stay alive
one more time definitely tiffany how
does tiffany like the diamonds had dish
thank you
leave the shape of your league why are
you getting
going on with yourself huh i'm about to
get this [ __ ]